tout de suite je suis avec la garde des
sceaux nicole belloubet juste moi et
bien vous avez répondu à une question
sur ce sujet c'est le sujet de la
responsabilité des élus
le gouvernement est finalement
favorables finalement à une réécriture
de la loi sur ce point il y à lui un
amendement qui a été adopté en
commission à l'assemblée que dit il
exactement
il ya un moment où bonjour jordy a
effectivement un amendement qui vient à
l'instant d'être adopté en commission
des lois à l'assemblée
cet amendement vient préciser la
jurisprudence actuelle en matière de
responsabilité pénale
je rappelle que la responsabilité pénale
des élus ne peut être engagée que dans
des conditions extrêmement restrictives
prévu par la loi faute de la loi fauchon
qui a été d'ailleurs à laquelle on doit
beaucoup pour le sénat est donc ce sont
des conditions restrictives et là l'idée
serait si j'ai bien lu l'amendement
adopté par les députés mais j'étais en
séance serait d'ajouter un élément qui
prennent en compte l'état des
connaissances scientifiques
autrement dit ça permettrait dans le
cadre d'une crise comme celle du comité
19 de tenir compte pour apprécier la
responsabilité des personnes des
décideurs de tenir compte de la réalité
des connaissances scientifiques et c'est
très important parce que si je peux me
permettre
un dernier mot cette responsabilité elle
est toujours appréciée au cas par cas
honteux non content très précisément de
la situation dans laquelle se trouvait
le décideur donc si la loi dit que cette
situation doit être appréciée au regard
des connaissances scientifiques c'est un
point important prologis et c'est très
différent de ce qui a été adopté par le
sénat pour oui oui c'est très différent
puisque à la lecture de
l'amendement qui a été enfin du texte
qui a été adopté par le sénat il me
semble que l'on part sur un principe
d'irresponsabilité sur un principe de
rupture d'égalité pour le déclenchement
de la responsabilité puisque la fournée
parce que juges les sénateurs un jeu wii
mais je peux le comprendre mais si je
pose sur ce texte un regard de juristes
je trouve qu'il ya une question de
rupture d'égalité qui me semble poser
problème entre les décideurs et vous
craignez aussi ça car ce sont les mots
d'edouard philippe que cela pose aucun
problème au niveau politique au niveau
de ce que pense que je pense là on voit
le débat qui est en train de monter je
suis certaine que les sénateurs les
parlementaires partagent cette opinion
là il ne faut pas que les responsables
politiques donnent l'impression qu'ils
veulent se dédouaner de leurs
responsabilités je pense que nous
partageons cela est donc l'écriture doit
être s'isoler et bien merci beaucoup si
amicale belloubet la garde des sceaux
qui était donc à mon micro l'instant
merci beaucoup et juste